you
good evening [__] mad flavor here
in my office relaxing getting ready for
the [__] fight you know me you people
like Joey where's the Garden of Good and
Evil where we will my [__] office in
the back I'm trying to get some [__]
music loaded up so we do this together
like [__] savages you
understand me cuz that's exactly what we
are
I can't see so I gotta wet my [__]
shields you follow me
what are you gonna do wait till you get
[__] old and you can't see this [__]
and play a little music have a little
chitchat and that's basically it you bad
[__] I'm sorry to do this
before you know I had to [__] get
this together and [__] like that
but hey we're here with will you find I
got so [__] tremendous edibles I
won't beat on a soul okay now I said it
Hey look I'm tugged oh boy I'm a mess
wrong color beam up
it's Saturday night whatever the [__] it
is November what fifth say who gives a
[__] you swinging dick and giving up
donut understand me
BAM let's crack this [__] here
we go
a little [__] UFO you [__]
we got everything tonight we got [__]
see
now you give me what we're going deep
into the murky waters
if you 18 head up down I got UFO lights
[__] out that's the feed for the
night [__] lights out now we got some
tremendous [__] cushions I'm taking
up a new shipment of stars [__]
Monday you understand me but for right
now I got a beeper telomere cure time
waits for nobody [__] 200
milligram [__] owns like nothing
give a [__]
let me tell you something people can't
eat these things these things will make
you [__] up Elizabeth you love it and
I'm buddy what I mean [__] you long beep
I told you it's solo flight leaves them
all jumpin up and down get food
poisoning yourself I can't deal with
that [__]
good restaurants
they can feature [__] wizardly look
at this
boom boom lights out if [__]
California
empty number one going down view Emily
love a bow - here are a few minutes for
the fluffy fight starts the chip name is
Daniel Joe is here never feel uncle
Joey's here oh [__] oh [__] and a new
dick tonight I went to soccer practice
at my daughter you might be lunch I went
for a little club to walk become a
couple telephones around and now I'm
Justin
because next sadly I'll be a [__]
[__] woods in Connecticut with you
[__] Foxwoods baby and then from
the show ends at nine will slip into the
bar will watch 205 together I'll be like
a fight companion when whoever goes to
the [__] show so that's how we're
doing this [__] understanding
but joking up with each other channel
was that last patent Atticus Michael
segment
[Music]
focus
it's all about the shopping it's called
White Sox luck
oh [__] the last word Gorilla Biscuits
[Music]
we got some and make repairs portable
ones cases birthplace
[Music]
paper due
and warfare
the old days let's have take the
coastline Oh a flexible job
[Music]
what time is it it's time to [__]
blow let's finish up
oh [__] this is my wall of fame right
there's my teacher mr. turnover that's
Darren Reagan
Reston least that's the [__] man look
at me straight out of Chicago [__]
that's my wife
that's uncle Joey you're young Joey
that's Pablo Escobar's daughter back
daughter who the [__] you think you're
dealing with here [__] let's go
burn if I look at it a CPC I'm gonna
have some before Town Hall June 30 1979
I went to see him August 4th 1979 this
is the bathroom of death this way take
my [__] dunks of death in the morning
[__] but look at this this is how I roll
the pipe is already filled up we're
gonna go outside I have some [__]
reefer here come from this pick a debt
oh yeah
this how we doing [__] I gotta
find the spot now give me a minute
right here the darkness
it's [__] lights out for real you
know I don't [__] around people I take
it deep deep deep into the murky waters
of [__] death here we go up which
over here there's a good spot feet they
go [__] uncle Joey in full effect
we can still smoke a bomb together the
darkness
man on fire [__] let's fill this
[__] big boy
my daughter still up I got a smoke
outside like a [__] burglar but what
are you gonna do at least work together
you know saying like a Karen Carpenter
song at least we'll [__] it together
forever I gotta hide from my daughter I
want to [__] victim
look at that even in the darkness you
see the smoke of death you understand me
you bad [__] don't [__] with me
next Friday night I'm in Boston I don't
care what you [__] need to do
you need to be there and then sadly I'm
at the Foxwoods casino blowing [__]
smoke rings bigger than this and then
November 18 time to come and take it
[__] Comedy Festival in Houston
suckers for years
I'm the joy don't play games the rest of
these [__] chumps you know look at me
take me into the darkness smoke some
reefer
but I'm here you understand me that's
all that [__] matters I'm here with
my [__] with the church or what's
happening now we don't give a [__]
anymore
put them living like [__] pirates
they go turn the [__] light off in
the yard and that's it we're done for
the [__] night at least we got a
little chitchat
the toothpick of debt this cleans out
the [__] pipe oh [__] and that's it
[__] at least we got the smoked
dog who does that
we went from light to darkness and back
to light you know why because I love you
[__] I'll do anything for you
[__] to the debt after all you
did for me [__] so let's go enjoy the
fights now we got some great fight Diego
Sanchez
Kukui are DEA you want predictions I got
no [__] predictions what am i I'm
just a regular fat [__] r-rated comic
swinging dick with my peeps and [__]
I'm your peeps you're my peeps and
together we're taking over this
[__]
stay black uncle Joey loves you to enjoy
the fights hit me up a little while
maybe we'll do a [__] two or three
bows here on the lighter I'd stay black